hey everyone it's Mike from orls here
and you know I just want to do a little
uh PSA little Public Service
Announcement uh regarding ninja Trader 8
you know I just want to make sure um you
know you all are running the most recent
version of ninja Trader 8 which is
version
8.1.2 one okay you know using older
versions can sometimes result in bugs
missing features and compatibility
issues um I don't want to say it slows
things down sometimes but you know
keeping up to dat you know is crucial to
having a smooth Trading experience now
to check your version on on what you're
running you just open the ninja Trader
control panel go to help and go to about
and you'll see it in there right version
8.12.18 say 1.1.7 or I know some Traders
are still even using the the older
version instead of 8.1 and above they're
still on 8. uh Z
Spot 28 or something like that so if you
want to update your software what you do
is you you go to Ninja Trader go to the
account uh um place a log to your
account you're going to enter your
password
here and you're going to go
inside okay and you see bottom left
corner ninja Trader download our
awardwinning trade platform for free
open there and you can see here right
the most recent release right here
download most recent release is
8.1.2 point1 Right which is the version
that's right here
oops right
8.1.2 one
okay now why is this important is
because yeah in in a couple of weeks
hopefully before the end of this month
I'm going to be releasing a newer
version of order order flows Trader and
we got some really great stuff um that's
coming out again you know if you're an
existing user of orderflows Trader you
will get the upgrade for free but you
need to be on the most recent version of
8.1.2 one because some of these features
you know take advantage of what is in
the most recent version so if you're on
an older version you're going to need to
update right if you're still on 8.0.2
eight for sure you got to update um it
doesn't work on 8 on versions ninja
Trader 7 so you I don't know if they
still support that but they do offer it
here and if you're on 8.1.1 point7
you're going to run into issues get on
to
8.1.2 point1 to take advantage of the
new features on the order flows Trader
when it comes out I mean I don't want to
talk about it get ahead of myself you
know i' I've got the first or sorry the
second version I've been testing it um
for a little while but it's about
halfway done we still have a lot more
features to put on there okay so what
you're going to do is you're going to
click on download right
here okay and you see um you know
depending on what you're using as your
web browser um oh what is this one
called I get them all mixed up uh this
one
is Edge Microsoft Edge sorry there
blanked out for a second um you're going
to save
it right you should always save it to
you know your download folder or
whatever um and then you're going to
open it and run it okay okay now you
know to be safe you might want to
consider backing up your data beforehand
and again if you want to find out how to
do that go to Ninja Traders um you know
support portal they'll show you how to
do it but people always ask me do I need
to uninstall the previous version of
ninja Trader if I'm installing the new
version I don't honestly I I just
installed the new version on top of it
um and go from there so again you know
if you haven't already please please
update ninja Trader to take advantage of
when we do release a new version of
orderflows Trader uh hopefully by the
end of this month which is February
2024 and again you know running the
latest version of ninja Trader is
essential to trade effectively and to
ensure everything is running smoothly
you know because you know sometimes you
know people say well Mike you know it's
not working properly then I look at
their version
of of a ninja Trader and some you know
there are people they send me their logs
and I see it's they're still on like not
even the most recent version of the
previous version of ninja Trader it' be
like on 8.0.2 7 or something like that
but definitely you want to get on the
most recent version
8.1.2 point1 and you know I'll be honest
normally I'm the type of person that's
goes into upgrades Kicking and Screaming
you know especially um you know major
upgrades and when ninja Trader first
released um 8.1
I waited right I waited several months
to get all you know let all the bugs get
out but 8.1 now has been out what is
that over a year or not a year but going
on a year this year um it's stable okay
you can do it you know and these smaller
updates
8.1.2 point1 you know they're
incremental okay and I I remember I had
a
conversation couple months ago with
Ninja Trader I was still on an earlier
version this one 8.1.1 7 and I went to
log into my ninja Trader account and I
got logged out or not logged out but
locked out okay because there was an
issue um
with let me see here if they have it in
their notes Here release notes
um you they say it in here see these are
all the little updates that they've made
there was here there was resolved a
scenario that could cause unexpected
failed logins applied to an account okay
that's the issue that I was having um so
anyway that's why it's important to make
sure you're on the most recent version
because last thing you want to do fire
up ninja Trader and you can't get in
right and if you're on the old version
you may run into that issue you may may
not but I ran into that issue that's why
I upgraded um you know months ago to the
new version but I still see people um
you know on the older version and again
I just just trying to help you out make
your life a little bit smoother cuz
again it is frustrating to get uh locked
out of your account all right everyone
thanks
byebye